[Music]
amid a roaring economy and the total
collapse of the Russia collusion
conspiracy theory Democrats there now
renewing calls for impeachment why it's
all a desperate attempt to derail and
destroy Trump's presidency let's take a
look it may well be a time for an
impeachment inquiry to begin the
Judiciary Committee as a whole is for at
least an inquiry of impeachment it's
reached a point where we have to open an
impeachment inquiry the President of the
United States of America needs to be
impeached we should begin impeachment
proceedings against Donald Trump not
something here now the reaction is the
Senate Judiciary Committee Chairman
Senator Lindsey Graham of the great
state of South Carolina sir how are you
good to see you good thank you all right
well it's clear Nancy Pelosi is speaker
and name only it's clear this is what
the media mob and and the Radical
Democrats are doing no solutions for the
American people right I don't think Matt
Towery great pollster said everyday that
combination of the green New Deal and
impeachment after four separate
exonerations that's not going to work
out well politically well I don't think
so I think Medicare for all means
Medicare for nobody so between their
radical agenda and their desire to
destroy a Trump you got to remember this
two years Muller looked at Trump 25
billion dollars 40 FBI agents 19 lawyers
2,800 subpoenas and they find no
collusion with the Russians the
Democrats will not take Muller's as the
final word here's what's going to happen
I don't think you can get the Democratic
nomination for president without
advocating for the impeachment of Donald
Trump I don't think you're going to be
able to survive in the Democratic Party
without a primary if you don't call for
Trump's impeachment and here's what I
think is going to happen the public's
gonna kick the Democrats out of power
and they're gonna reelect the president
if he stays focused on doing the job for
the American people there's a lot of
talk Butler doesn't want to come in you
have coming
yeah that's the command you said fine
well I I know Democrats that's still
their dream but there are questions I
think you and Jim Jordan and Mark
Meadows might have that are a little
different when did he know there was no
collusion with Russia important question
if he had time for taxi medallions and
loan applications and everything else
why didn't he investigate the dossier
why did he only hire Democratic donors
why did he hire one of his people to be
happen to be a lawyer for Hillary
Clinton's foundation why did he hire
Andrew Weissman licensed to lie in
Sidney Powell's book he once withheld
exculpatory evidence the most atrocious
record Enron accounting and and Merrill
executives nine oh he lost in the
Supreme Court would you like the answer
to those questions because I would yeah
but I'd ask him did you find any
collusion between the Trump campaign in
Russia did President Trump do anything
to stop you from doing your job that's
what I would ask him the answer is no
Trump did not Clube with the Russians we
know for sure he didn't we now know that
Trump didn't gave 1.4 million documents
to the special counsel everybody around
president testified for hours the bottom
line is the Democrats want an outcome
the Muller report didn't give them the
outcome they wanted and they're going to
keep going until they get the outcome
they want and here's what's going to
happen if the president will focus on
infrastructure prescription drugs and
keeping the country safe he's going to
win and Nancy Pelosi and those that
crowd's going to get kicked out of
office well is there a justifiable
reason with that broad mandate that
Muller had and it was broad it took him
way off course yeah
how does he then justify the main part
of the mandate which is Russian
interference and ignore the Hillary
dirty dossier Russia to be honest with
you on that one his job his job was to
find out did candidate Trump colluded
with the Russians did our president when
he was running for office when the
election cost the Russians helped him
and he was all ready to expand out
cetera yeah but but he didn't that's
what bars gonna do
that's what Horowitz is going to do you
can say this any way you would like but
here's the bottom line
after two years of a political rectal
exam
nobody's been looked at more than Trump
they found nothing but the answer for
the Democrats is Trump's gotta go they
will not beat him at the ballot box if
they try to impeach him they're going to
ensure his reelection I want the
American people know that Bob Muller did
his job he looked at Trump every way you
could look at Trump and he found nothing
and this is just political revenge it's
going to blow up in their face and I
can't wait to 2020 well said Senator
Graham
we'll see you again soon thank you so
much for being with us